I want to ask you about something you
did fairly recently that intrigues me
cuz I used to do it a lot when I was
younger I would take road trips with my
friends and I just loved driving around
America but I haven't done it in such a
long time and I'm told you just did this
I did earlier in the year across country
in January yes you went cross-country in
January you know that was that was when
I could do it and I I knew I was gonna
work for about five months in a row and
sometimes I get little stir-crazy yep so
I wanted to go somewhere beforehand and
I had to get from LA to New York and
actually it was all instigated because
my little cat was not feeling well and
she was pretty I mean I don't want to
bring it down you look very concerned
I'm very concerned you know what this is
you know what this is called right now
that's the power of chickens talk about
that later so Hugh your cat wasn't
feeling well I just didn't think she'd
make it on another flight so I I took an
RV and I took her across with it and I
had some friends join me oh that's cool
everyone was into the idea yeah so was
this all dudes you were going with all
ladies what was it what are we talking
about - and - and nobody people didn't
even know it oh I didn't know how I
committed this is like us by how it came
these were these weren't even couples
this is like it was yeah I'm swingin RV
all of a sudden you're in a swinging RV
the only downer is a sick cat in the
back you all start to have wine and
she's like I know I know
Joe and then work to people were going
through divorces so they were really in
the mood to just get kind of cut loose I
know it's kind of here may spin off this
is the movie I want now right I would
watch this movie
Marisa Tomei and some frustrated friends
put it that way
well no okay listen I guess I'm working
here in the moment to come up with a
movie did anyone did anything happen on
the trip or no is it pretty any liaisons
yeah no not that I know of
right right perhaps yeah I mean yeah how
they had the crowd end up doing that she
didn't make it X sorry it's that that's
no good but they're not right at all
we're gonna get great it was a wonderful
send off on a great yeah what cat
doesn't want to leave this is somewhere
in Iowa
going up to heaven to go down
[Applause]
you